here are celebrity full names prepare to
be shocked her full name is Billy eilish
pirate Baird O'Connell Dove Cameron's
full name is Chloe Celeste hosterman and
you know what she looks like a Chloe she
looks like a Chloe Celeste halsey's full
name is Ashley Nicolette Frangipani this
one I didn't see coming Jamie Foxx's
full name is Eric Marlon Bishop Mindy
kailyn's full name is Vera Mindy
chilingum Jason Derulo's full name is
Jason Joel Derulo his stage name is
actually the phonetic spelling of his
name
also what a good last name Adele's full
name is Adele Laurie blue Atkins and her
first name was actually almost blue okay
this one is a little bit of a mouthful
Ray Fine's full name is Rafe Nathaniel
twistleton Wickham finds Reese
Witherspoon's full name is Laura Jean
Reese Witherspoon
Rhys is her mother's last name and
Witherspoon is her father's and Olivia
Wilde's full name is Olivia Jane
cockburn and we better not get Shadow
banned for saying that